hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
given that most people in the present
probably know about Plutarch mainly as a
writer of biographies the parallel lives
as well as some other biographies it's
it's entirely reasonable that we would
expect to find some biographical
material or at least mentions in
Plutarch short work on controlling anger
and he does not disappoint as a matter
of fact he's going to tell us about
quite a few people from ancient times
and we should think about why bring
these sorts of things up they are
examples that we can emulate that we can
think about that we can mull over so to
speak we could even model ourselves
after them to some degree and Plutarch
himself is going to tell us that I
always strive to collect tsunaging to
bring together and to peruse or to you
know more literally think about
onag ignos gain the the
not just the sayings and the Deeds of
the philosophers but of other people as
well now he's got a very funny thing
that he says here about fools or
literally those who do not possess mind
or intellect these people say that
philosophers lack bile and you might say
well
that sounds like a medical problem to me
bile holos was associated with anger and
so you know the philosophers lacking
that would actually be better off than
the rest of us because they don't get
provoked you know by their bodily
reactions into anger Plutarch thinks
that that is completely wrong right
philosophers can get angry too he knows
plenty of philosophers he interacts with
them but he's saying I don't want to
just look at philosophers who at that
time would have been the people to give
most of the advice philosophers
playwrights other other people who are
considered wise about how to control
anger I want to look at people who have
to deal with anger all the time who
don't have special training in this and
so he says I'm not only going to look at
the sayings and deeds of the
philosophers I'm not going to put those
aside but even more those of Kings uh
you know basaleon and despots or tyrants
and you know what's the difference
between these well a king is a better
kind of ruler than a tyrant but they're
both monarchical they're both one person
rule right so he's going to look at
these and try to draw some useful
examples or even conclusions from them
he doesn't actually begin with Philip of
Macedon but I think that we should
because he talks about Philip uh so
often and so he begins by talking about
this guy
Arcadian the akaian who is always
railing against Philip Philip was trying
to unite all of Greece underneath the
Macedonian monarchy and then you know to
create an army that then he would take
to fight Persia which is what his son
Alexander will do and so Arcadia on the
akane is always railing against Philip
right and so when Arcadian visited
Macedonia he's going into enemy
territory Philip's friends thought that
he should not be let off but punished
what does Philip do Philip does the
exact opposite he meets him he treats
him kindly he sends him presence gifts
he tells his friends later to ask how
Arcadian announced spoke of him to the
Greeks and here is where the friends
turned out to be wrong and Philip turned
out to be right the friends are saying
oh well he says good things about you
now it looks like you won him over and
so Philip says I'm a better physician
I'm a better doctor than you isn't isn't
that an interesting way to frame it this
viewing anger is a medical problem or
conflict as well not giving into it
another case Philip is being you know
defamed again uh blasphemy ass is
literally the term there being you know
they're saying nasty things about him uh
in Olympia and so some people so the
Greeks should pay for it because they
spoke evil of Philip even though they
were being well treated and then Philip
says well
what would they say if they are being
badly treated so he's able to brush it
off with kind of a comparison and a joke
right
um
a little bit later on he says just as
someone said if Philip when he had
raised the city of olinthus to the
ground but he could not possibly
repopulate a city so large uh he says
Plutarch says you can address anger and
say you're able to overturn and Destroy
and throw down but to raise up and
preserve and spare and forbear is the
work of mildness and forgiveness and
moderation in passion the work of a
Camillus or mattelis or aristidase or as
Socrates but to attach oneself to the
wound and sting as the part of an ant or
a horse fly so even Phillip sometimes
gives in but we see that you know much
of the time it's possible to display
these other attitudes to raise up to
preserve to spare to refrain from right
these are the works as he says of
mildness
and uh forgiveness
being forgiving towards other
understanding towards other and a
measured amount of the passion
metropathias so Philip furnishes us some
some interesting uh examples and talking
points who else does Plutarch bring up
this guy antigonus with his men they're
saying bad things about him once again
near his tent he can hear them they're
off on campaigns and he says listen
Buddies go over there so I can't hear
you reviling me uh go further off to
abuse me why because he knows that he's
liable to get angry with them if he
keeps listening to this Ptolemy has
another interesting example here Ptolemy
is one of the successors of Alexander
and uh Ptolemy is making fun of a
scholar a pedant it's actually
translated here gramaticon a grammar
teacher right for being ignorant and
then the
um the grammar teacher says I shall tell
you he has some who is peleus's father
he says I'll tell you if you'll tell me
who is the father of Lagos and this is a
joke that he's making about the
um
perhaps illegitimate uh birth conception
of Ptolemy himself he might have been
Philip of macedon's kid and so you know
people are like oh we're going to punish
this guy and Ptolemy says listen a king
shouldn't make jokes if he can't take
jokes so if you're going to abuse
somebody else in a joking way you got to
be able to roll with it when other
people do that to you instead of getting
angry as you are on my behalf he also
talks about this guy porus he's taken
captive by Alexander who was subject to
fits of rage and temper and Alexander
asks them how he uh Taurus says uh treat
me like a king meaning don't treat me as
if I'm a king act like a king yourself
Alexander and Alexander said is there
nothing more and porus says in the words
like a king there is everything why
because the king of the Gods Zeus is the
gentle one right the Athenians call him
boisterous but punishment is the work of
the furies and Spirits not of the high
gods and Olympian deities so he's saying
don't just act like a king act like a
god king that means be be gentle be
forgiving be decent with me
Plutarch is also going to bring up a
number of examples of people not
allowing anger to interfere with their
work their goals their activities in
Conflict particularly in war and so he
talks about
um
this Roman general uh you know the
rhodian says to the Roman general
servant what you say matters nothing to
me but what your master doesn't say he
brings up Sophocles and uh you know
neopolimus who's a hero
um they're trying to do things go into
battle without being angry and he talks
about barbarians poisoning their their
weapons true bravery has no need of this
because it's been dipped in reason but
rage and fury are rotten and easily
broken then he talks about the Spartans
going into battle without being angry
playing pipes to remove from their
Fighting Man the spirit of anger you
might say well what's that about I mean
these strongest of Warriors at least
until the thebans beat them
um why are they trying to remove anger
because anger is not as effective for
Warfare as is reason right he's got a
several other great examples agathies is
engaging in a Siege and people are like
how are you going to pay for your
mercenaries and he's like well after
they sack your city I'm going to pay him
out of that he refuses to get angry he
responds to an insult with a joke
antigonist when some of the men on the
wall of a town are jeering at him
because he's got a deformity he says I
thought my face was handsome and then he
gets the last laugh he takes the town he
sells the people as slaves who are
joking at him jeering at him and he says
well you know
if you're going to insult me again I'll
talk to your Masters and so all of these
people are able to
avoid falling into the foolishness that
comes out of getting angry and losing
control the last thing that he talks
about in terms of like real life
examples
orators and Advocates need to avoid
getting angry because they become
ineffective they make mistakes in their
task of using language to convince when
they allow themselves to get angry so he
brings up this guy the friends of
satiris the samian when he was going to
plead a case would stop up his ears with
wax so he wouldn't screw things up by
getting angry at the insults of his
enemies saying things while he's trying
to present his case so these are all a
number of good examples from ancient
times that Plutarch thinks would be
helpful for his readers in figuring out
how to respond when people are trying to
push your buttons people are trying to
provoke you people are trying to get you
to get angry and thereby to do foolish
things to lose control probably to take
revenge that you shouldn't take rather
than reconciling and removing the
conflicts we could come up with
additional examples in our own time
obviously Plutarch lived you know over 2
000 years ago uh well not quite 2 000
years ago but close to two Millennia ago
so you know some of his examples are a
little bit harder for us to relate to
but if we think about the general ideas
that are involved in this and we mull
them over I think that we can actually
derive a lot of useful Reflections from
that